[Musique]
depuis le 16 juin les députés de la
commission d' enquête consacrée à
l'épidémie de covin 19 auditionnent les
acteurs de la crise sanitaire monde
médical mais aussi ancien ministre et
ancien directeur généraux de la santé
tout l'été lcp vous propose de revivre
ces auditions aujourd'hui celle de jean
yves grall directeur général de la santé
de 2011 à 2013 sous xavier bertrand et
marisol touraine donc qu'elle était
alors la politique de l'état en matière
de masques éléments de réponse de ceux
des gs après l'audition de jérôme
salomon de benoît vallée nous allons
entendre monsieur jean yves grall
directeur général de la santé de 2011 à
monsieur directeur je vous remercie
d'avoir répondu à notre sollicitation
cette solide cette audition devra nous
permettre aussi d'aborder des questions
directement opérationnel puisque vous
avez été à plusieurs reprises
directeur d'une agence régionale de
santé depuis novembre 2016 vous êtes à
la tête de la rs d'auvergne et rhône
alpes
nous pourrons donc profiter de votre
analyse de la gestion de la crise au
niveau local des relations que vous avez
eu aussi avec les préfets les élus
locaux ainsi que des difficultés
vous avez pu rencontrer dans votre
région et les moyens que vous nous
préconisé pour y remédier avant de vous
donner la parole je vais vous demander
de prêter serment
en effet l'article 6 de l'ordonance du
17 novembre 58 relatives au
fonctionnement des assemblées
parlementaires impose aux personnes
auditionnées par une commission denquête
de prêter serment de dire la vérité
toute la vérité rien que la vérité
je vous invite donc à lever la main
droite est à dire je le jure je le jure
merci cette audition est donc publique
diffusée est consultable en vidéo et
fera l'objet d'un compte rendu écrit qui
sera publié monsieur vous avez la parole
pour un cours propos liminaire qui
précédera notre échange sous forme de
questions réponses
merci beaucoup madame la présidente
monsieur le rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs les députés
médecins et cardiologue de formation
j'ai exercé les fonctions de directeur
général de la santé du 13 mai 2011 au 30
septembre 2013 date à laquelle j'ai pris
les fonctions de directeur de l'agencé
régionale de santé du nord pas de calais
et avant d'être directeur général de la
santé j'étais directeur général de
l'agencé régionale de santé de lorraine
en premier lieu il me paraît important
de resituer le contexte d'or de ma prise
de fonction qui venaient en succession
de monsieur didier houssin et je me
souviens d'un contexte général de
défiance vis-à-vis de la de la
prévention en matière de sécurité
sanitaire à cette époque et en
particulier on parlait beaucoup des
stocks stratégiques
à l'époque et tout ceci à la suite des
dispositions qui avaient été prises lors
de la grippe h1n1 est bien sûr cette ce
retour d'expérience sur la grippe h1n1
avait donné lieu à de nombreux rapports
commission denquête ou de rapport la
cour des comptes et l'ambiance générale
sur le sujet était un petit peu on en a
fait beaucoup
on en a fait trop et tout ceci coûte
très cher voilà un peu l'ambiance que
j'ai découvert en arrivant à cette
époque là ceci concernait bien sûr les
vaccins mais aussi les masques
dans cette appréciation générale neuf
ans après j'ai retrouvé les éléments de
mon passage comme directeur général la
santé et je vais les résumés sont de mon
point de vue sous deux points
particuliers en matière de sécurité
sanitaire tout d'abord en premier lieu
un certain nombre de textes concernant
la préparation à la réponse de l'état
aux situations exceptionnelles en
matière sanitaire et j'y ajoute dans ce
dans ce premier point la participation
de la constitution du plan pandémie
grippale 2011 cette époque là est un
deuxième point une réflexion sur les
stocks stratégiques d'état gérées par
l'eprus et en particulier les évolutions
vis-à-vis des masques dans ce cadre là
avec l'avis du hcsp qui est survenu en
juillet 2011 et la doctrine sgdsn publié
en mai 2013
donc voilà les éléments dont je suis
donc à votre disposition pour répondre à
vos questions
bien évidemment merci beaucoup
votre propos qui a été vraiment bref
vous avez bien raison non mais c'est
bien l'essentiel étant les changes avec
les parlementaires
moi j'aurais peut-être une question
est-ce que vous pouvez nous rappeler
l'historique justement de l'évolution de
cette doctrine en matière de stocks
d'équipements destinés à assurer la
protection des populations et des
soignants parce qu'il ya eu beaucoup de
choses qui ont été dites contredite par
fois votre prénom votre successeur nous
en a parlé aussi mais j'aimerais avoir
votre vision et puis votre regard porté
sur cette crise en tant que directeur
d'ailleurs est ce parce que vous êtes
redevenu
et bien comment avez vous apprécié
évidemment entre les ordres qui vous
arrive est comment vous avez pu évaluer
ça je vais essayer d'être concis non
parce que je je quand je suis arrivé je
vous ai donné le contexte je vais pas y
revenir
il y avait cinq cent soixante millions
de masques ffp2 dans les soc les stocks
stratégiques il y avait 800 millions de
masques chirurgicaux et quelque chose
comme 100 millions de masques
chirurgicaux pédiatrique donc ce qu'il
faisait à peu près 1,4 milliard de
masques au total qui était dans les
stocks dans les stocks stratégiques
à la suite du retour d'expérience de
2011 et dans le cadre de la
programmation qui avaient été données ou
qui allait être donnée à l'eprus le
directeur général de la santé de
l'époque en avril 2010 sollicite de la
part du haut conseil de la santé
publique
une expertise visant à déterminer à
l'aune de ce qui s'était passé en
l'occurrence une une difficulté
de l'utilisation des masques ffp2 pour
des raisons techniques qui faisait que
l'observance n'était pas très bonne
et là le sujet qui se pose est dans le
contexte que je viens de vous dire de
masques ffp2 qui venait à péremption est
toute la question sur la masse de masse
dont je vous pose est est la question
est ce qu'on régresse qu'on recommande
une masse aussi importante et donc ils
demandaient au ssp de dire son avis de
poser un avis sur faut-il continuer à
voir des stocks stratégiques de masques
si oui lesquelles quel dimensionnement
pour tous ceux ci et pour quels types de
populations ou de personnes dans ce
cadre là et tout ceci faisait suite
aussi il faut le ch est né cet avis avec
les dispositions du plan pandémie
grippale de 2009 qui déterminait un
certain nombre d'indications et
notamment sur ses masques en sachant que
l'objectif général et qui n'a pas varié
de mon point de vue du moins quand je
suis parti il était toujours là c'était
grosso modo un milliard de masques
chirurgicale et lorsque je pars en fin
2000 2013 il y as je crois 624 millions
de masques chirurgicaux et j'en passe la
commande avant de partir de 100 millions
supplémentaires ce qui aboutit à quelque
chose comme cette comme 720 millions
comment dire
en fin 2014 dans dans ces eaux là et le
stock de masques ffp2 quand je parlais
de 380 millions de masques ffp2 donc ça
veut dire qu'on a une des éléments
conséquent donc je reviens sur cette
demande de dire où hcsp ces éléments là
afin de poser une doctrine derrière
suite à la grippe h1n1 et aux données du
plan pandémie grippale
cet avis revient en 2011 donc et
détermine détermine plusieurs éléments
il dit qu'il faut garder un stock que
mon dire de masques chirurgicaux mais
aussi ffp2 par contre il revient sur les
doctrines d'utilisation des masques ffp2
en étant beaucoup plus restrictif
puisque en auparavant et notamment sur
les données de la pandémie de du plan
pandémie grippale et ce qui s'était
passé c'était des masques ffp2 pour tous
les soignants et pour tout les personnes
en lien avec le public et c'était assez
large et s'était fondée donc le stock
était fondée sur tout ceci donc le en
2011 le hcsp produit cet avis qui dit
donc nous avons besoin de stocks nous
avons besoin d'avoir une gestion plus
dynamique de ce stock est et si possible
de faire un stock dit tournant c'est à
dire que ne pas attendre la péremption
des masques pour les utiliser dans des
établissements de santé et donc de faire
un tour pour commander augmenter la
rotation peut-être pour ne pas les
perdre et pas les pubs pas les détruire
vers les utiliser avant et émet aussi je
ne suis plus si ciel la mêlée mais
globalement on y reviendra comme ça la
notion aussi de faire attention de
d'accous dans l'acquisition des masques
c'est à dire que d'arriver à péremption
de tout un stock de 600 millions par
exemple et qui nous qui oblige à un
recommandé plutôt de lisser les
acquisitions pour obtenir une cible à 1
milliard et donc 200 millions par an à
partir de 2013 puisque c'est là que ça a
commencé pour arriver à un milliard à
terre mais qui permet toujours d'avoir
un stock de de masques monde est de
bonne qualité et aux normes en
permanence c'était ça et les éléments à
partir de ce moment là se pose donc dé
facto quelle doctrine parce que
automatiquement le côté restreint de
l'avis du hcsp rendait le nombre de ffp
deux nécessaires dans un stock national
beaucoup moindre defacto puisque les
indications était moindre et donc tout
le le sujet était
de mettre ça en oeuvre et donc de voir
qu'elle était à ce moment là le niveau
de stocks nécessaires survient se met en
place un travail à ce moment là d'une
autre façon c'est à dire que le sgdsn
prend la main pour organiser des travail
pour aboutir un avis sur la doctrine de
protection des travailleurs
à l'aune de cette de cette nouvelle à
vie qui change un peu la donne a
également et le sgdsn
sorin avis en mai 2013 dans lequel ils
indiquent deux choses il indique qu'il
fait référence bien évidemment aux avis
du duo conseil la santé publique et
détermine que par rapport à ce qu'il
était avant c'est-à-dire des populations
de travailleurs
face au public et ça représentait tous
les administrations certes tout n'a pas
besoin de ffp 2 mai du match
chirurgicale et de aimé un avis qui est
totalement calé sur le droit du travail
sur le code du travail qui indique que
chaque employeur est responsable de la
de la sécurité et la santé de ses
employés et que donc par essence il lui
revient de faire nécessaire dans ce
compte là et le hdz à ce moment-là
transmet à l'ensemble des ministères là
[Musique]
la doctrine en leur disant au ministère
va vous d'adapter maintenant dans votre
champ de compétence les principes cadre
de ce2 ce2 cette doctrine tels que je
viens de vous le donner donc voilà voilà
grosso modo et donc moi
après 7,7 à vie qui survient mai 2013
je pars fin septembre 2013 dans la je
lance un certain nombre de choses sur
lesquelles on pourra revenir pour
déterminer à ce moment là comment on
adapte ce gie dans le dans le secteur
santé dans le ministère de la santé sur
sur ces éléments la voilà sur ce premier
point peut-être sur le deuxième on verra
mais votre disposition rapportait il ya
merci sur le directeur général la
présidente vous a posé la question
essentielle sur sur cette stratégie qui
a évolué en effet de façon très très
importante en 2011 en 2013
une question qu'on a posés à vos
successeurs
c'est la question du contrôle de ces
stocks tactique aussi je la pose aussi
au directeur de la r est ce que vous
êtes
puisqu'il semble que la définition de
ces stocks tactique reviennent aux ars
éventuellement le vin c'est une question
est-ce que ça revient à la grèce où nos
établissements hospitaliers enfin aux
établissements locaux qui en charge du
contrôle de ces stocks de leur
définition de leur évaluation
actuellement bon cela nous paraît un peu
flou on n'a pas jusqu'à ce stade trouver
des éléments très clair et très précis
sur la définition des besoins sur leurs
contres leur évaluation donc eller et
leur contrôle sur tout et je voulais
aussi vous vous demandez sur 7
en gros on tourne toujours aussi sur les
masques chirurgicaux sur une évaluation
autour d'un milliard sur les besoins qui
sont qui sont là sous votre direction
générale comment vous aviez est ce que
vous aviez procéder à une évaluation des
stocks
je crois que vous évoquez aussi l
expertise sur le la péremption de ces de
ses stocks
qu est-ce qu il y avait déjà une
réflexion à ce ce niveau sur les stocks
qui datait du début des années 2000 2000
2000 2005
oui je vais me permettre de non pas de
faire une digression mais de donner des
éléments très très factuelle est très
important me semble-t-il dans la
discussion qui j'espère permettront
d'éclairer un peu le débat le sujet
commence par une instruction agences
régionales de santé en date du 2
novembre 2011 effectué par le ministre
de l'époque xavier bertrand je pense que
c'est ça que vous avez entendu parler
et cette instruction aux ars faisait
suite à la création des ars and an avant
et mettez en évidence donner un certain
nombre d'instructions concernant les
champs de la sécurité sanitaire en
général est évoquée en gros si point
l'organisation des ars en lien avec les
préfets en cours de crise donc c'est
tout de la d2 le les modalités de
fonctionnement les cellules de crise etc
les éléments demandant aux ars lorsque
des textes ont pris de relayer le
travail de l'eprus vis-à-vis de la
réserve sanitaire en région demande et
d'harmoniser les différents volets
sanitaires des différents plans au sens
des régions ou des ou des zones
d'ailleurs c'était plus les zones et je
vais revenir la formation des soignants
aux gestes d'urgence et à l'aide
médicale urgente par les établissements
de référence et la comptine les plans de
continuité de l'état
il y avait un sixième point celui là
tous sont importants mais celui-là
particulièrement dans notre discussion
c'est d'actualiser la gestion des moyens
de réponse des établissements de santé
aux situations exceptionnelles et c'est
là qu'on arrive à la distinction entre
des stocks stratégiques
les stocks stratégiques tels qu'ils sont
listés et qui n'appelle pas les les deux
pays je le dis tout de suite quitte à
une liste dont les masques dont les
masques ffp2 dont les masques donc c'est
à dire le stock stratégique géré par
l'eprus et à l'époque on parle
d'équipements tactique qui deviendront
des moyens tactiques après qui est une
liste fermée de dispositifs qui sont les
avec un lien avec des situations
exceptionnelles de type nrbc nucléaire
biologique radiologique lui pardon et
chimiques par nos limites et qui tient à
des tenues spécifiques dans ce cadre-là
des unités de décontamination des postes
médicaux avancés poste ps m
tout se fasse et des postes mobiles
médicaux le quatrième point c'est je
crois certaines antidote et il ya un
cinquième ou sixième point dans là
dedans qui dit bien ce que sont les
équipements tactique
ces équipements tactique après ça suit
tout au long de vocation à être disposés
dans les établissements de santé de
référence et d'être disposé également
dans les établissements de santé sièges
de samu dans la dans la région en gros
un par département et ses stops tactique
c'est pas des stops tactics et des
équipements tactiques sont rémunérés
très clairement par une mission
d'intérêt général un financement de m
deux missions d'intérêt général qui est
versé via les ars aux établissements qui
en disposent et ses missions d'intérêt
général sont dans la liste je crois que
ces acquisitions et renouvellement des
équipements tactique pour faire face à
une situation exceptionnelle dans les
établissements de santé
c'est ça les équipements et moyens
tactiques par rapport aux stocks
stratégiques
il n'y a pas dans les moyens tactiques
de masques ffp2 c'est une liste fermée
qui donne lieu à un financement
spécifique par une mission d'intérêt
général qui répartis à due concurrence
et entre les différents établissements
fonction de de l'équipement qu'ils ont
et ce sujet là il est médiée par un
système d'information qui s'appelle cij
est jeune et busi geste mais c'est ça a
été a dû être décrits plus loin qui est
un dispositif qui étend en interface
entre
le mil l'eprus je crois et les ars pour
suivre etc et les établissements ses
moyens tactiques et pour adapter aussi
les rémunérations des milk en fonction
des moyens disposez donc ça c'est le
c'est le point crucial il n'y a pas de
masques ffp2 deux principes dans les
moyens tactiques dans les équipements
tactique et ça c'est toujours comme ça
et donc leurs échanges sur six ges se
fait sur la base de tout ceci
voilà ça c'est ce premier point
monsieur le rapporteur j'ai votre votre
deuxième question c'est est oui
non
c'est laissé à la disposition totale de
des établissements de santé les les
dates tout d'abord il faut préciser que
à la fois l'avis du hcsp est à la fois
la doctrine du sgdsn ne préjuge
absolument pas de l'absence de stocks
quel qu'il soit le fait que lier une
recommandation du sdsm au niveau cadre
de l'ensemble du des ministères puisque
le hd scène est rattaché au premier
ministre
et donne donc une doctrine qui
s'applique à tous les ministères charge
à chaque ministère d'organiser lui-même
la traduction de la doctrine selon ses
critères qui ne sont pas les mêmes dans
le système de santé oms le ministère du
travail etc etc
et de ce point de vue là il n'y a jamais
eu à ma connaissance de remise en cause
sur le principe d'un stock de ffp2
stratégique dans la mesure où on est
toujours resté et je pense qu'on peut
d'une certaine mesure d'évacuer c'était
on est toujours les deux montants sur la
ligne du nain du milliard avec un
programme lycée avec l'eprus de
recommande de 100 millions par an
jusqu'à atteindre le milliard et puis
après tout se fait en fonction des
percussions avec les notions de lissage
et du stock tournant comme je vous ai
saas et les doctrines de gestion qui ont
été mis en place sur les ffp2 ou même le
stock de ffp2 et rester je crois en tout
cas quand je suis parti il était encore
à près de 400 380 millions et il n'a pas
été décidé
quand j'étais là s'est posé la question
de renouveler des ffp2 en demie
onze en 2012 2013 en 2011 il ya eu un
abondement de 25 millions je crois de
ffp2 qui faisait suite à une commande
anciennes donc on a continué à récupérer
des masques ffp2 à ce moment là et il
avait été décidé en 2011 que en 2012 et
compte tenu du niveau des stocks qui
était quasiment hostoak cible à peu de
choses près et de la nouvelle doctrine
qui allait arriver qu'ils allaient faire
baisser defacto la consommation et
l'utilisation du fer de verre cet avis
il n'était pas question de remettre de
l'achat de ffp2 avant 2014 ou 2015 mais
tout simplement ces deux là c'est de la
gestion sur la base de deux se
de ce constat s'est posé la question
suite au hd est celle de savoir bon très
bien on a une doctrine de d'utilisation
de par l'avis du hcsp et on a un élément
qui détermine que chaque employeur mais
qui est d'ailleurs je crois dans le sdsm
n'est pas quelque chose qui arrive comme
ça c'est un c'est un principe qui
existait dans le code du travail depuis
je crois 2008-2009 et je crois que dans
le plan pandémie on en parlait déjà
par contre l'élément nouveau c'était
cette notion de ffp2 qui changeait de
beaucoup de la nature
c'est ça le sujet alors après la la la
la
le sujet de l'arrivée de tout ceci était
de déterminer justement que me disiez le
stock nécessaire dans ce cadre-là
faut-il un stock de quel niveau à quelle
nature est donc j'ai à l'époque je
pourrais vous faire passer les documents
sollicités
l'asm par exemple pour demander quelles
sont les capacités des établissements
qui fabrique des masques à
réagir rapidement puisque il y avait
cette notion aussi de deux de stock
à quel niveau le même et le niveau des
stocks il est dépendant aussi de la
capacité de régénérer vite ou pas en
fonction d'un certain nombre de critères
voilà et puis je sais je crois que
j'avais aussi écrit à l'époque aux ars
au mois de juin 2013 si je me souviens
bien pour leur indiquer voilà la
doctrine vient de changer d instruction
complémentaire viendront pour vous
avertir de la de comment se déclinera le
sujet dans l'est dans le secteur santé
le moment venu c'était une alerte et un
avertissement comme quoi la doctrine
desseigne rejoignait le le comment dire
le le document et à ce moment là s'est
posé la question et nous avons réfléchi
et le sujet n'était pas tranché quand je
suis parti s'il fallait un stock et
qu'elle dimensionnement du stock de ffp2
voilà c'est ça sur le contrôle sur le
contrôle il n'y a pas d'élément et les
ars à ma connaissance mais pas mon
niveau tous les cas n'a pas reçu
d'instructions pour regarder les stocks
dans des établissements qu'ils soient
médico sociaux où qu'ils soient
établissements de santé puisqu'il
appartient à chaque gestionnaire bien
sûr d'assurer pour son pour son cadre et
donc il n'ya pas de suivi à ma
connaissance des ars ddd des stocks dans
les établissements où ailleurs en passe
en branle en plus par le fait que
l'utilisation des masques notamment
il est très variable d'un établissement
à l'autre d'une structure à l'autre et
des préconisations des choses qui se
font en routine dans les établissements
donc c'est très difficile de le
déterminer
donc le le contrôle ou le suivi qu'il y
a il est sûr et c'est un deuxième temps
que je vais je me permets peut-être deux
parce que ça c'est important sur le
circuit de distribution des stocks des
stocks stratégiques nous on a des stocks
stratégiques expliqué ce qui était les
moyens tactiques et les stocks
stratégiques qui ont une liste de deux
composants et qui sont répartis il ya
une circulaire interministérielle en
juillet ou août 2013 que jusqu'au signe
avec le directeur de la sécurité civile
je crois indiquant voilà quel est le
circuit de stockage et de distribution
des produits des stocks stratégiques
importants stocks stratégiques se divise
en deux se divise en deux mais ça reste
des stocks stratégiques d'état qui sont
stockés au niveau national il ya eu je
crois juste après mon départ on avait
lancé le principe d'un stockage
du côté de vitry-le-françois pour qui
était une opération de réunir l'ensemble
des stagnations on a un seul avec un
objectif de rationalisation qui était
tout à fait justifiée parce qu'il en
avait 15 je crois sur sur l'ensemble du
territoire on en fait un et ce stock
national est accompagné de stock zonaux
au niveau des zones de défense et dans
chaque zone de défense
il ya un plan zonal de mobilisation
entre le préfet de zone qu'ils préfet de
région actuellement en auvergne
rhône-alpes c'est comme ça en tous les
cas et le directeur de la rs pour
organiser le déploiement de ce stop
zonal situe à la zone vers les
départements ouvert l'infra zonal
notamment pour les comprimés diodes au
niveau des communes où il ya tout un
plan départemental qui accompagne ce
plan zonal est l'organisation la mise en
oeuvre de ce dispositif il est fait sous
la commande du directeur de la rs et du
direct et du préfet de zone bien
évidemment les directeurs des ars et il
ya un suivi deux fois par an de de la
nature et du nombre des dispositifs de
stock zonal au sein de la zone qui se
fait entre l'eprus et la rs et nous
avons à relever deux fois par an de là
comment dire de la la quantité ou de la
nature de ce qui existe en plateforme
zonal qui bouge pas beaucoup et
si je me souviens en 2018 nous avions un
million neuf ou un million huit se
réserve de ffp2 qui était toujours en
stock mais c'était péremption très
sûrement et 18 millions de masques
chirurgicaux qui n'apparaissait plus en
donc on suit ça comme ça mais par contre
nous n'avons pas de contrôle ad hoc de
des stocks dans les établissements de
santé ou dans les établissements
médico-sociaux et nous avons pas
d'instruction à ce fait là pour ce qui
nous concerne je crois que je ne sais
pas je pense que je pense qu'il faudra
resserrer le dispositif pour être plus
lisible je pense une certaine mesure je
ne je pense que c'est très difficile
d'évaluer des stocks compte tenu de la
diversité des interventions des
activités qui sont et des pratiques qui
longe et des établissements qui
utilisent le masque larga manu d'autres
beaucoup moins bon c'est une affaire de
pratiques internes mais c'est très
difficile à quantifier avec b voilà
merci donc je vais passer la parole à
mes collègues
damien abad merci beaucoup madame la
présidente monsieur le directeur
merci pour ces éléments d'information je
pense que le sujet effectivement
centrale sur la question des masques et
notamment sur période entre 2011 et 2013
c'est de bien comprendre
est ce qu'il ya eu changement de
doctrine ou pas donc drogue c'est clair
ce que ce que vous avez expliqué sur le
fait effectivement qu'on n'a pas de
changement de doctrine nous confirmer
bien ni dans le cadre de l'instruction
ni dans le cadre ensuite éventuellement
de la circulaire qu'il ya eu aussi en
novembre 2011 pense qu'il faut que ce
qu'on essaye de comprendre comment il ya
eu une évolution sur les stocks de
masques à la fois les stocks dit
stratégiques les stocks tactique et vous
avez bien le préciser aussi ce que ce
qu'on appelait les moyens tactiques
puisque et je crois que c'est un point
également important moi je voudrais
savoir finalement peut-être de remarques
ou de questions
d'abord nous dire clairement on vous
avait donné la liste
quels ont été les les suivis les
commandes et tout ce que vous avez fait
pendant cette période entre 2011 et 2013
pour justement maintenir ses stocks à
flot et également donc les ffp2 comme
comme vous l'avez évoqué voit que c'est
un point important est ce que du coup
vous allez sentiment que l'eprus était
utile et en tout cas qu'on est en
évolution par la suite peut handicaper
le processus de processus d'achats de
masques ou pas est un deuxième point
peut-être davantage sur le regard actuel
notamment sur la question sur la
question des tests puisque c'est une
question également qui est centrale et
que nous posons est de voir comment sur
le sur le terrain et un peu
pratique cette question-là pu a pu être
abordé par un parent vous notamment
je vais être un peu brutale je vous prie
de m'excuser parce que par ailleurs on
me dit que vous êtes un acteur dans le
domaine de la santé très efficace
pardonnez moi mais moi je considère que
fâcheux mais en parallèle l'activité des
services de l'état à celui d'une société
privée et quand je regarde de l'intérêt
d'une société privée de la gestion des
stocks qu'il soit 1 gestion des stocks
de matières premières comme des produits
finis pour un gestionnaire de stock
totalement basée sur le diagramme de
gantt first in first out
qu'il s'agisse des stocks stratégiques
comme des stocks tactique pour moi on ne
peut pas jeter 600 millions ne masque on
ne peut pas détruire 600 millions de
masques dans une société privée un
directeur de logistique de la gestion
des stocks
il est viré le lendemain le problème si
vous voulez monsieur le directeur c'est
que la sanction de je vais être très dur
un peu brutale pardonnez-moi de
l'incompétence quant à la gestion des
stocks la sanction elle est politique et
ce sont les politiques c'est le
président de la république au moment
d'une élection résidentielle
ce sont des députés des sénateurs qui en
subissent les conséquences
et je trouve que la sanction est lourde
pour des politiques finalement sont
assez docile par rapport à une erreur
comme celle qui a été commise au moment
de la gestion de stock ya eu un vrai
sujet à ce moment là moi je voudrais que
vous m'indiquer très sincèrement comment
est-ce qu'on peut laisser passer la
destruction de 600 millions de masques
dans une conjoncture économique comme
celle que la france aujourd'hui à à
vivre et du coup comme celle que la
france aura à subir
parce que la réalité c'est que le
confinement enfin c'est mon avis
personnel nous avons été confinés trop
longtemps parce que nous avons manqué de
masques
en conséquence les
deux victimes le plus important ne
seront pas des victimes sanitaires et
des victimes du coc vide de la copie 19
les plus importantes victimes seront
économique
merci comment peut-on avoir hélas votre
gsm vous êtes président des ars de
france mais essayer de dégager un peu de
cette mission à l'image d'un préfet de
la démat savez qui gère l'ensemble du
corps préfectoral
qu'est ce qui marche pas dans les ars
pour qu'on a des réponses qu'il soit
aussi différentes qu'on a pu avoir sur
le terrain
deuxièmement la logistique pardonnez moi
n'importe quelle pharmacie d'officine
il ya une gestion des stocks et on sait
parfaitement que tel médicament est
permis à telle heure et qu'il reste
trois boîtes
la commande est automatique comme en
france en 2020 on n'arrive pas à faire
ça expliquez-moi et d'ailleurs vous le
savez mieux que moi c'est que dans les
différents établissements
chacun avait sa réserve secrète ne
disais rien se débrouiller et ça a été
un système départ tout sépare reproche
que je vous fais en direct mais on doit
sortir plus fort de tout ça la troisième
chose est ce que oui ou non vous avez
cru au ministre lorsque vous étiez en
charge ou lorsque vous l'avez peut-être
en tant que directeur général diaries du
rhône alpes auvergne pour dire il ya des
choses qui vont pas si jamais il ya une
pandémie
est-ce que vous avez été lanceur d'
alerte et je sais que vous avez fait des
publications très intéressantes en
matière des prévisions de stratégie de
plan blanc j'ai lu vos publications est
donc vraiment ça m'intéresserait de
savoir et matous dernière question
monsieur le directeur votre doctrine à
vous parce que j'ai bien écouté ce matin
le professeur fontanes et qui a été je
crois très clair je passe devant mes
collègues le masque nous protège est ce
que vous êtes de ceux qui pensent que il
faudra continuer d'en porter pendant
longtemps comme le font les pays
asiatiques
si on veut mieux se protéger tant qu'on
n'a pas la maîtrise de ce virus ou
d'autres à venir
merci merci je vais vous donner la
parole
on passera vos questions suivant oui
merci madame la présidente
monsieur monsieur le député juste un
point général qui compte c'est ce qui
anime tous venir il faut bien être clair
il n'y a pas de stock tactique de
masques
il y a des stocks stratégiques et il y a
des masques dans les établissements mais
qui n'appartiennent pas aux stocks
tactique dont je parlais tout à l'heure
d'importants donc on n'a pas la main sur
des stocks tactique en tant que tel sur
le territoire les stocks qui existent
ils sont sur la plateforme saunal enfin
ici sont ils doivent y être et c'est là
que le plan zonal de mobilisation permet
de les mobiliser en tant que besoin
c'est un point sur les ffp2 sur les cas
durant mon passage de 2011 2013
j'ai posé je crois un acte de recommande
de 100 millions de masques chirurgicaux
toujours dans cette idée de remonter à
au milliard tranquillement dans cette
optique et joseph kony de lissage des
acquisitions pour pas se retrouver en
permanence en bas du jour on en en
rupture et de stock tournant pour les
utiliser et je n'ai pas commandés de
masques ffp2 durant ma période tout
simplement parce que nous étions près de
la cible et que la doctrine ou les
conditions d'utilisation venait de
changer et automatiquement vis-à-vis de
ce qui s'était passé dans le plan
pandémie grippale d'avant qui confiait
des masques ffp2 à tout le monde
enfin tout le monde a beaucoup plus de
gens là restent l'apport restrictif du
hasch du hcsp faisait que nous étions
presque à la cible à 580 ou 600 millions
à ce moment là et que ça ne justifiez
pas compte tenu des durées de péremption
qu'on en achète d'autres dans l'immédiat
et donc quand je suis parti avec 380
millions et 620 millions de masques plus
100 millions qu'elle arrive et c'est sur
les prusse
j'ai pas j'ai pas n'ai pas d'avis
particulier je pense que c'est un
instrument excusez moi du terme
extrêmement utiles sur les trois
vocations qui sont les leurs gérer les
stocks
les stocks stratégiques l'établissement
pharmaceutique quoi le la réserve
sanitaire et lépide et et oui c'était
ces choses là au départ qui s'est
enrichie en passant à santé publique
france
l'essentiel n'est pas de mon point de
vue là l'étiquette ou la structure c'est
les fonctions qui sont affectés et donc
les fonds les fonctions de l'eprus ont
été ou doivent être et ont été effectués
dans le cas de santé publique france
mais dire que ce soit les puces ou santé
publique france l'essentiel c'est que
les fonctions soit soit effectuée peu
importe de mon côté sur sur les tests
sur les tests nous avons eu une
augmentation progressive quand j'ai
commencé à m'occuper du colis de 10,9
c'était le 7 février avec le le cluster
des contamines où on est on est on est
parti dans et je crois qu'on n'a pas
trop mal géré cette affaire là le seul
établissement en février qui effectuer
des tests dans notre région c'était le
centre national de référence de lyon de
monsieur li na et petit à petit au fur
et à mesure de la delà de la manière de
l'épidémie on est monté à je crois 6,6
en tout six centres par diffusion de la
technique avec des gros établissements
et dans un second temps ça a été donnée
aux laboratoires médicaux puis aux
laboratoires départementaux de brantôme
et ternaires si bien qu'on est passé à
l'heure actuelle de 1 en début février a
je crois 45 ou 48 sites sur l'ensemble
du territoire qui concourent au
diagnostic et près de 317
quelque chose comme ça un site de
prélèvement sur l'ensemble du territoire
un des sujets au départ c'était
effectivement c'est de monter en
puissance et puis bien sûr l'art et la
possibilité des sites de réaliser de
plus en plus de tester c'est pour ça
qu'on a aussi été plus loin puisque au
début avec le cnr de lyon et puis après
ça s'est diffusée et une politique très
suivi en tout cas pour ce que je connais
en auvergne rhône-alpes qui a été
d'avoir un suivi de contact racing
extrêmement rigoureux et je me souviens
très bien qu'eux on avez
les résultats de façon en routine des
tests pcr bien évidemment et que le 5
mars vous souviendrez toujours nous
avions 61 ou 62 cas suivis je les
connais c'est à mon niveau je savais ce
qui c'était et puis il ya eu le le la
dissémination du cluster de mulot sur
l'ensemble du territoire qui a fait
qu'on a quintuplé le nombre de cas en
une semaine avec ce qu'ils étaient trois
ou quatre départements dont le vôtre
monsieur à battre pour passer aux douze
départements de la région au 13 mars
donc c'était l'explosion et ce moment là
on s'est retrouvé un petit peu enfin
voilà donc c'est ce qui s'est passé avec
une craie mentation dans la possibilité
de tests diagnostiques
donc c'est monter progressivement en
puissance et nous n'avons pas eu de
problème à ma connaissance comme ça sur
le fait de tester les suspicions ou les
où les malades sur la notion de deux de
gestion des stocks et d'organisation je
voudrais quand même faire préciser
quelque chose c'est que
nous fonctionnons avec des textes et des
règles issues d'ailleurs des lois
diverses qui organise dans le pays
l'organisation de l'état les stocks et
la gestion des stocks n'étaient pas du
fait et ne sont pas du fait des agences
régionales de santé elles sont
clairement à l'eprus qui a des
pharmaciens qui détermine et suivent
leurs stocks comme ça en qualité etc
et moi je n'ai jamais été alertés si je
m'en souviens en 2011 2013 sur un
problème de qualité intrinsèque des
stocks mais je considère qu'à ce niveau
là c'est du travail quand même de ceux
qui sont chargés de les gérer de les
mener de faire en sorte qu'on ait
toujours des stocks
enfin utilisable et dans lequel voilà
sur sur le fait que
[Musique]
l'organisation de l'état vous trouvez
que l'est
après c'est une affaire dit il il ya
deux choses là dedans c'est la doctrine
qu'est-ce qu'on fait démasquer
manifestement semble-t-il on n'a pas
recommandé d'autres masques à partir de
ces éléments là et deuxièmement
l'organisation qui fait en sorte qu'on
en dispose qu'on l'ait qu'on les libère
et qu on les organise à ce point de vue
là il me semble important de vous
revenir sur la circulaire que j'avais
cosigné donc j'en profite
qui stipule bien que l'envoi des
produits de santé dont les masques à
partir des stocks stratégiques se fait
sur un centre sur une une
comment dire une un mode opératoire très
simple c'est à dire que sa part du stock
central et ça va dans les plates formes
zonal je crois qu'il y avait sept ou
neuf et à partir de là du stock zonal
sert distribués par les grossistes
répartiteurs d'un côté ou par les
logisticiens vers les établissements de
santé il ya deux voies et
ceci se fait au niveau de plateforme
logistique avec des contrats je crois
qui est qui était passé ou qui sont
passées entre l'eprus et santé publique
france avec les logisticiens les
grossistes répartiteurs
c'est ça la doctrine et à ma
connaissance elle n'a pas varié depuis
sur le suivi des masques ma foi elle se
fait au niveau du stock national dans le
cadre dans le cadre précis sur les
agences régionales de santé
je me permettrai n'étant qu'un modeste
exécutant dans ce cadre-là de vous
suggérer peut-être lors d'une audition
de d'entendre les directeurs des ars ès
qualité j'allais dire sur l'action de la
grèce dans la crise je ne vais pas me
défausser mais je vais vous dire mais ça
je pense que
sur les masques particulier les agences
régionales de santé ont déjà employé ce
terme et je veux me permettent de nous
pleurons colmater des brèches un peu
partout et dans certains le savent bien
c'est à dire que nous avions à notre nom
nous avions à notre disposition un stock
tampon que nous avions nous mêmes
constitués en lien avec la préfecture
avec des dons ou des masques ffp2 qui
étaient récupérés dans les
administrations et tout ça et nous
n'avions pas à notre niveau
vu sur les approvisionnements qui venait
de paris puisqu'il ne passait pas par la
plateforme zonal et de ce fait là nous
avons couru en permanence et le
directeur général lui même sur les
informations pour pouvoir appeler par
tout le monde
la rs ont appelé la grèce et c'est très
bien pour essayer de savoir où étaient
les masques où étaient les manques et
nous nous avons avec mes collègues je
peux en témoigner avec mes équipes qui
ont été admirables depuis le 7 février
je peux vous assurer pour essayer de
colmater soûles et sous les lazzis ou
soûles et sous les reproches permanents
et les ars ont vraiment en permanence
essayez d'aller dans l'ehpad dans
l'établissement vers les médecins
libéraux pour essayer de leur donner des
masques qu'on nous disait qu'ils
n'arrivaient pas qu'ils n'arrivaient pas
parfois parce que les masques de les
masquer de de charente-maritime arrivés
dans la loire et les masques du rhône
arriver
en mai les noirs et parfois et parfois
avec avec avec beaucoup de coulage sur
le circuit avec beaucoup de gens qui
portent ffp2 dans la rue beaucoup de
matches et un gigot de ci de là et les
pharmaciens nous disait souvent qu'il
avait du mal à voir le rapprochement
entre le nombre de masques initialement
partie et ceux qui arrivent et parce que
j'ai pas de rapprochement et qu' il
était pas rare qu'il y ait des cartons
déchiré donc ça c'est un premier point
sur les ars et les masques sur les ars
et les données épidémiologiques
nous avons en région un double système
nous avons le système des
épidémiologistes c'est-à-dire santé
publique france c'est à dire les six qui
ne sont pas sous l'autorité du directeur
général de la rs et
par contre c'est le directeur de la rs
avec le préfet qui se retrouve face aux
élus qui se retrouve face aux aux médias
à la population aux professionnels sur
la base de chiffres qui ne sont pas les
leurs dont les chiffres qui remontent à
la fois de l'hôpital c'est à dire par le
système civiques et les chiffres qui
remontent des ehpad ne sont pas les
chiffres des ars elles sont faites par
des systèmes vous à nous pour ce qui
concerne les ehpad et civiques pour ce
qui concerne des établissements
de santé et je rajouterais
vous me demandez ce que je pense qu'il
faudrait faire à des éléments nous ne
sommes incapables d'obtenir à l'heure
actuelle le nombre de décès qui se passe
dans ce pays au jour le jour
pourquoi tout simplement parce que le
dispositif de déclaration passe encore
par les papiers bleus enfin et pas se
parler
les mairies et il faudrait sûrement
réfléchir à avoir quelque chose
d'instantanés d'obligatoire et non pas
facultatif comme actuellement pour avoir
systèmes d'information qui nous donne
des choses basiques
voilà deux exemples sûrement que si vous
nous fait l'amabilité de nous re
convoqué on pourra peut-être explorer le
sujet sur toutes les facettes de la rs
mais je merci on a encore des questions
à vous poser dans un vieux monsieur
viger excusez moi monsieur ligier sur
les agrès je crois que j'ai fait le fait
le point vous m'aviez interrogé sur le
jeu s'cusez moi j'ai mal écrite mais oui
que chacun se le dise quand vous avez
fini de parler vous appuyer sa voix la
présidente
est-ce que vous avez pris votre plume
pour faire des préconisations aux
ministres successifs sur l'insuffisance
préparation du pays face à des pandémies
qui pouvait arriver parce que vous
alliez cochet comme l'a dit au début de
mon propos toutes les cases non non
absolument pas par contre ce que j'ai
fait moi dans mon agent c'est un
organisé à un retour d'expérience non
pas trois mois après mais au fil de
l'eau puisque
j'ai eu le chance de pouvoir disposer
d'un inspecteur igas que j'ai accepté de
se mettre dès le départ le suivi au jour
le jour pour faire un retex vivant et
non par texte j'allais dire statique
après et donc à l'occasion je le ferai
remonter mais je n'ai pas fait des
préconisations moi même à mon niveau
au fur et à mesure des auditions je
m'interroge sur le nombre de masques
utilisable que nous avions à l'instant t
je veux dire par là que vous nous dit
tout à l'heure je suis arrivé en 2011 il
y avait 1 4 milliard à peu près de
masques dont je crois 850 millions de à
peu près de chirurgicaux oui mais votre
prédécesseur à cette table est votre
successeur
dgs nous disait il y a eu mise en place
d'une date de péremption à partir de
2010 sur les masques s'agissant de
dispositifs médicaux
peut-on considérer que les masques avant
2010 était encore des masques utilisable
après 2010
merci à la présidente également sur les
masses c'est parce que si on réfléchit
quand même à cette histoire c'est ici
même mes tongs et 600 millions de plus
valable ça fait un coût unitaire normal
je pas 5 centimes donc on se retrouve à
30 millions de valeur mais par contre
qu'on doit les racheter dans le cadre
l'urgence avec un coût de la matière
première qui a largement augmenté sa
fesse plutôt 50 centimes près de 150
millions donc en fait c'est même pas que
le chef logisticiens il est viré c'est
toute l'entreprise elle s'est effondrée
c'est beaucoup plus grave que ça si on
le prend comme ça mais en fait est ce
que le problème c'est pas juste que vous
savez sur dispositifs médicaux il ya des
sociétés fabricantes et distributrice
qui sont certifiés iso 13485 pour vendre
du matériel médical et jan hudec il ya
la matériovigilance il ya des tests
yahia il ya tout un tas de choses en
fait qu'ils sont qui ne se font pas par
contre au niveau de l'état est ce que
c'est le point faible c'est pas juste là
sur toutes ces questions de suivi des
stocks matériovigilance finalement où ça
a péché et danser et la question elle
s'étend pour les faits p2 je suis
d'accord avec mon collègue bord
julien c'est qu'on n'a finalement pas
besoin beau souvent en pratique médicale
normal de ffp2 est-ce que vous pensez
que le problème viendrait pas aussi du
fait comme parfois c'est pas le même
fournisseur puisque ce sont pas des
dispositifs médicaux ils ce sont des
équipements de protection individuelle
et donc le fait qu'une autre norme soit
appliquée et que le coût unitaire est
aussi plus important est ce que vous
pensez pas que simplement c'est la
raison pour laquelle ça n'a jamais été
considéré comme capital dans un stock
stratégique
ainsi on comprend bien la pré l'ensemble
de nos auditions le péché originel de la
protection en termes de masques ont
début de crise c'est l'absence de stocks
puisque
on vous rappeler vos objectifs qui ont
toujours été tenue d'un milliard de
milliard de masques il y a non pas
d'aider des masques qui me semblaient en
mauvais état mais une norme qui tombe
peut-être que vous avez des informations
sur le sujet même si vous étiez plus à
la direction
c'est ce qui nous indique énorme qui
tombe en 2014 sur des nécessités des
fans et des impératifs de non
contamination de deux masques lié
d'ailleurs à des des nouvelles règles
pour les producteurs eux-mêmes donc
cette norme tombe on découvre 600 mille
masques 600 millions de masques qui sont
plus utilisables
on les détruit et on reconstitue pas le
stock
bon alors ensuite je comprends bien que
les hôpitaux gèrent eux mêmes leur stock
et d'ailleurs ya jamais eu de problème
avec les hôpitaux donc c'est qui gérait
normalement leurs stocks ce n'est pas le
sujet sous ges et les stocks sans trop
alors par contre
j'arrive quand même pas comprendre vous
dit deux fois par an on va vérifier le
droit de tirage de chaque ars
peut-être parce que dans le stock
central dans le stock central
on vérifie qu on a bien cette
affectation on mais si c'est le cas on
n'aurait pas dû être confrontés aux
problèmes qu'on a actuellement donc est
ce que c'est ce que vous avez des stocks
prêt affecté par région est ce que
voulais visualiser et et pourquoi ça se
passe comme ça quoi pour ce carrousel
les ars monsieur le directeur moi je
considère que ça aurait pu être un outil
extrêmement intéressant pour les
territoires pour finalement la gestion
de la santé la gestion territoriale de
la santé sauf que aujourd'hui comme
d'habitude en france d'ailleurs
nous sommes au milieu du gué que les ars
sont finalement des préfet bis sans
autonomie sans pouvoir et que c'est
toute la problématique des ars sont nos
territoires et qu' elle ne dispose pas
par exemple suffisamment de pouvoirs
financiers pour pouvoir être très engagé
sur chacun des territoires de la façon
la plus pertinente possible sachant que
des hauts de france à la corse ou de la
bretagne
à l'est les choses ne sont pas enfin la
santé ne doit pas être appréhendées de
la même façon et je pense qu'il serait
intéressant de laisser à l'état tout son
actif toute son action régaliennes et
budgétaires et que par ailleurs les
agressent pourrait avoir cette cette
liberté et cette déconcentration cette
décentralisation réel qui serait bien
plus efficace
ça c'est le premier sujet et je me
l'enlève le micro parce que je ne veux
pas que la deuxième partie de ma de ma
prise de parole soit au procès non non
on est en commission denquête madame au
coni dans ce cas là il faut pas la poser
si vous voulez pas désolé mais non alors
monsieur abad
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire plus au
moment de entre 2011 et 2013
quelle était la doctrine sur le port du
masque on sait que c'est quelque chose
qui a fait débat qui fait débat encore
aujourd'hui avec certains qui
considéraient que le port du masque
n'est pas forcément utile et nécessaire
en toutes circonstances on a tout à
l'heure auditionné le professeur
delfraissy qui a expliqué que compte
tenu de vin voilà de la forte prégnance
du virus notamment dans les milieux
confinés le port du masque est utile à
ce que à ce moment là il ya une doctrine
qui éclaire sur sur la question du port
du masque sachant que c'est il ya bien
sûr une différence de culture entre
notre pays et d'autres pays
et puis je suis directeur même si je
pense qu'on aura l'occasion de revenir
sur le fonctionnement des ars dans
d'autres temps d'autres dans d'autres
circonstances et peut-être dans d'autres
auditions
je ne résiste pas à poser juste une
question il y a eu un match olympique
lyonnais juventus de turin pendant juste
avant le
quand le tri-nations en caux vide est-ce
que vous avez constaté dans les hôpitaux
de lyon au tour est bien un surcroît de
cas et de contamination est d'arriver
dans les hôpitaux
je vais vous repassez la parole je vais
vous poser une question totalement naïve
mais que je pense des gens le droit de
se poser est ce que vous pensez que
quand il s'est avéré sur les territoires
que nous manquions de matériel et nous
l'avons tous constaté à un moment mais
avec cette profusion de messages
incohérent et vous l'avez rappelé en dix
ans les masques ceci les masses cela
sauf que masquer tous publics n'étaient
pas les mêmes que ceux dont on avait
besoin dans les établissements donc il
ya eu une confusion très très médiatisé
si j'ose dire est amplifié parce qu'on
avait que ça à regarder et qu'on était
confiné j'irais jusqu'à dire est ce que
vous pensez que la profusion de
commandes qui a pu avoir par des tas de
donneurs d'ordres à ce moment là a pu
aussi continué de contrarier finalement
la répartition du matériel dont avaient
besoin les établissements les ars je
vais répondre à toutes les questions
bien sûr je vais excusez moi je vais
prendre un petit peu d'abord sur la
doctrine sur les masques
la doctrine était représenté par l'avis
du hcsp cet avis stipulé bien et ça n'a
jamais été remis en cause de parmi tous
les avis qu'ils ont eu lieu jusqu'à
présent un certain nombre de types de
masques en fonction des populations et
dans cet avis il était stipulé donc les
fèves p2 pour les soignants
particulièrement exposées en particulier
c'est qu'il faisait des investigations
at il veut aussi il était mentionné dans
l'est dans les productions animales tout
ça c'était sa figure est dedans et il
parlait du match amical pour les
personnels en lien avec le public sur
les soigner en général etc et il indiqué
le port du masque recommandé en période
épidémique dans l'est dans les
transports en commun pour la population
et dans les lieux recevant du public a
retiré après bien évidemment mais ces
textos dans le dans le dans le leur dans
l'avis du hcsp et la doctrine à l'époque
ne s'était pas à vrai dire poser
spécifiquement parce que moi j'étais un
dgs venir j'ai eu quelques crise à gérer
mais plutôt de teint de pêche à dire
dans ce cadre là est la question ne
s'est pas vraiment posé mais la doctrine
était plutôt que le masque est un
élément important contre le contre les
transmission virale que le masque je me
permets de le dire est un élément
extrêmement important mais pas le seul
des mesures barrières et que ça suppose
de bien le maître de bien le suivre et
aussi d'avoir des mesures barrières
autour dont on ne soulignera jamais
assez l'importance se laver les mains
etc etc
je pense que cette crise parmi les
choses je l'espère qui resteront c'est
là
l'appropriation par la population gestes
barrières qui nous ce qui n'est qu'une
s'attache pas coco vide 19 qui s'attache
aussi aux épidémies de grippe qu'on a
régulièrement etc etc
non le match ol juventus n'a pas eu de
de conséquence sur des cas que nous
aurions pu détecter à la suite et à
l'époque turin ne faisait pas partie des
zones atteintes par le coronavirus
lors du match et qui avait donné lieu à
des débats il a été maintenu et il n'y a
pas eu de conséquence de deux
d'hospitalisation de déclaration de cas
à la suite qu'ils auraient être fait un
bond sur sur le suivi de la qualité des
masques suivi de la qualité intrinsèque
des masques et donc leur caractère
efficient puisque effectivement si on
il faut pas que ce soit des masques
fictifs et le journal a besoin on
découvre qu'ils servent pas cetc c'est
le travail et la mission
de l'établissement pharmaceutique
qu'elle est pruski à des pharmaciens et
qui sont chargés de les faire vérifier
et à mon niveau je n'ai jamais eu des
alertes sur ces vérifications pendant
que j'étais directeur général de la
santé comme quoi il y avait un problème
tout cas ça ne m'a jamais remonté et
j'en aurais entendu parler c'était le
cas sur le fait qu'ils soient
comment dire utilisable je n'ai pas à
mon niveau à l'époque fait de demande
spécifique sur le sujet sûrement en
partie puisque les acquisitions étaient
relativement récente de 2006 2009 2011 à
peu près
mais je je je considère que c'est de la
mission de l'établissement
pharmaceutique d'assurer la gestion et
la maintenance de tous ceux ci mais je
n'ai pas sollicité plus que ça je n'ai
pas été interpellé sur le sujet sur la
la la médecine de ville et les les
professionnels de santé jeu il ya les
médecins mais il ya aussi nous avions
tous les deux points nous avions avant
dans la gestion à mon niveau tous les
mercredis entre 13h30 et 14h30 pendant
la crise un lien hebdomadaire avec
l'ensemble des professionnels libéraux
au niveau des ordres au niveau des ures
ps on faisait un point séquence est de
1h de façon à voir les difficultés qui
se posait et nous avons deux par le
stock tampon que nous avions réussi à
constituer en lien avec la préfecture
dans ce que je voudrais affecté au
conseil de l'ordre des différents
départements certain nombre de masques
de façon régulière pour essayer de
changer
le deuxième point 2-2 comment dire de
deux d'approvisionnement des
professionnels libéraux c'est les
pharmacies et les pharmacies qui sont
livrés par les grossistes répartiteurs
ou par geodis dans le cas précis voilà
c'était
voilà je suis désolé pendant on sait pas
compris ce n'était pas ça enfin c'était
important de le préciser mais ma
question c'est plutôt depuis la nouvelle
doctrine en ville comment a t'on gérer
finalement at on pris en considération
que éventuellement on pouvait
accompagner les professionnels de santé
en ville en leur disant peut-être
pourriez-vous avoir un stock pas du tout
pendant la crise la part dans gélis
était important d'en parler aussi
effectivement mais je peux il répondra
bien sûr qui a signé les contrats cadres
à spf
à l'époque je me souviens pas qu'il y
avait eu un élément particulier
simplement la doctrine comme vous l'avez
dit était que dé facto le ffp2 avec une
utilisation beaucoup plus restrictive
est essentiellement les personnels à
risque pour soignants qui font des
explorations y compris les prélèvements
comme sur l'absence de stocks
monsieur pencher je crois que il ya eu
une rupture en moment où
[Musique]
je crois que jérôme seulement on avait
parlé d'une revue de doctrine je crois
que c'est en 2018 sur le fait d'avoir
une gestion plus dynamique des stocks en
partant d'un stock que je crois de 200
millions qui devaient s'organiser de ce
côté là le le déstockage la destruction
viennent du niveau national au niveau de
santé publique france en l'occurrence
qui détermine la péremption qui
détermine linlin utilisation des masques
et qui en tire les conséquences et tout
se sait par contre la direction générale
de la santé qui donne ordre sur la base
ou acceptation de destruction ou qui
donnent indications 2 de condos de
commandes et ça a toujours été comme ça
c'est toujours comme ça de ce côté là
sur les fichiers
tout ceci appelle sûrement
c'est un des éléments qu'il faudra
regarder la suite aussi c'est la mise à
jour de l'ensemble des fichiers partout
à la fois des professionnels à la fois
aussi des pharmacies parce que j'ai le
souvenir d'une pharmacie qu'on essaie de
réapprovisionner tant bien que mal et
qui n'étaient pas listées aux niveaux
nationaux qui ne risquait pas de
recevoir des masses mais enfin bon c'est
des cdd petite histoire mais qui
justifie qu'on se sera sûrement un des
éléments de revoir les choses sur les
ars et les territoires ça c'est tout ce
sont des bonnes questions celle là aussi
je des agences régionales de santé sont
des agences qui ont vocation à d a
déployé sur l'ensemble du territoire
dont elles ont la charge la politique
nationale en l'adaptant bien sûr aux
réalités locales dont la notion de cadre
qui est le nôtre et nous avons des
directeurs
territoriaux départementaux qui sont en
lien direct avec le directeur général de
la rs et qui organise les éléments de la
doctrine et delà de la politique de
santé sur leur territoire en lien avec
les préfets en lien avec les élus et
tout l'enjeu pour nous c'est d'avoir
sept des personnes de qualité moi j'ai
la grande chance en auvergne rhône-alpes
d'avoir réussi à avoir une équipe de
d'été qui ont été renforcées par des
dispositions prises par le ministère
très récemment par le ministre qui a
donné un statut ou des rémunérations ou
un cadre d'emplois spécifiques pour ces
directeurs territoriaux de façon à ce
qu' il soit je vais venir armés et
qu'ils aient une une qu'on puisse
recruter des gens extrêmement adapté à
sa pour aller pendant la crise en
auvergne rhône-alpes
tous les matins à 8h30 j'avais une
réunion avec le préfet de région et ses
équipes et le recteur tous les matins à
8h30
on a fait ça et dans chaque département
tous les matins je peux dire papa
l'heure mais chaque d'été avec consigne
de voir avec son préfet de département
pour un point tous les matins ça prenait
le temps que ça prenait mais ça
permettait vraiment d'avoir 7,7 cette
approche très intégrée et je peux je
crois pouvoir dire que de ce côté là ça
a été une vraie réussite 7
interministériel it et il y avait pas
d'histoire
le préfet s'était clairement sous
l'autorité ou la coordination très forte
des préfets que se faisait l'action de
l'état au sens là dont les ars sur le
secteur santé
après un des éléments peut-être pour
revenir je reste sous les 1 res de ce
que dit monsieur borovick est ce que
nous avons est ce que nous avions les
moyens
est ce que les agences ont les moyens
est ce qu'ils ont du pouvoir entre
guillemets ou est ce que oui
elles ont beaucoup de pouvoir elles ont
beaucoup de possibilités d'action je
pense qu'il faut revoir un certain
nombre de choses et je suis je vais le
dire j'en profite
c'est pas moins de rs qu'il faut c'est
plus drs plus drs et je crois dans un
contexte tout à fait adapté avec
l'ensemble des préfets et moi dans ma
région
certains vous diront linverse mais de
mon côté ça s'est très bien passé et il
n'y avait pas une feuille de papier
entre nous sur la conduite des
opérations et avec les élus bas certains
ici peuvent en témoigner sûrement nous
essayons d'avoir un lien absolument
absolument régulier que ce soit les
d'été où le directeur général de la rs
qu'ils avaient au bout du fil en direct
dès qu'il y avait besoin et je crois
qu'il y avait une donc voilà donc je
fais je vous fais l'état de de ma
connaissance et de bas de mon expérience
mais il faut aussi le dire parce que
voilà sûrement vers les autres france
c'est pareil il ya eu vraiment un
rapprochement ars préfets et préfets de
département et élus maires et
parlementaires et toutes les semaines on
avait des franchement il faut rendre
hommage parfois quand les choses
fonctionnent de cette manière quoi
les colonisations en faire une des
réflexions qui est lancé c'est est ce
qu'on doit aller jusqu'aux fêtes qui est
des élus qui rentre dans des conseils
d'administration des ars aux élus
départementaux et régionaux ça fait
partie des monsieurs vigier me demander
je me demandais tout à l'heure un
certain nombre de choses et si nous
avions si j'avais écrit non a écrit bien
évidemment par contre nous avons écrit
les directeurs dares nourrit de tout
ceci et on entend les ars sont une
structure jeune qui a 10 ans et qui
apprend et qui évolue en permanence à ne
cesse pas d'évoluer et elle a encore
évolué grâce à fin grâce ou à cause de
cette crise et donc nous avons des
propositions que nous avons fait
d'intégrer beaucoup mieux les élus à nos
côtés j'allais dire sous sous le mode
d'un conseil d'administration et non
plus d'un conseil de surveillance nous
avons fait remonter cette demande là qui
inclurait aussi enfin après c'est un peu
de la composition administrative a fermé
qui composeraient chaque président de
cede notamment aussi voilà donc c'est un
sens on a bien entendu cette idée et
puis on a vu combien cette ce travail
était important et notamment sur le fond
des sujets pour pour l'apport de chacun
et c'était très complémentaires et vous
parlez des masques madame la présidente
oui un certain nombre de collectivités
territoriales ont commandé des masques
ont eu des masques aussi par des
jumelages qui existe et lyon était
jumelée avec une ville chinoise et par
des circuits qu'on arrivait à voir les
masques arrivé et je peux témoigner que
c'était
extrêmement précieux pour pour arriver à
ça veut dire à assurer un une
complémentation pour l'ensemble des
structures
ceci étant nous avons eu beaucoup de
difficultés globalement sur les stocks
de masques sur l'attention qu'il y avait
pour acquérir des masques pour en avoir
mais je crois que si la tension était
forte dans les établissements de santé
peut-être un peu moins dans les secteurs
médico sociaux encore faut voir je ne
crois pas que en auvergne rhône alpes
est une des structures qui soit
réellement à 0 un jour de masques je ne
crois pas un seul qui n'empêche qu'ils
avaient une tension très forte c'est
peut-être plus pour la ville que nous
avons plus de difficultés mais ça c'est
peut-être une question de
l'approvisionnement dans un autre cadre
dont j'ai parlé je crois avoir à peu
près répondu à ce que vous me poser
comme question alors monsieur bré aussi
que voulez vous la reine précision oui
oui effectivement je alors d'abord je
vais aller dans votre sens dans le sens
où effectivement il ya une bonne
communication entre la rs et les élus en
auvergne rhône-alpes
je peux en témoigner il y compris
justement sur les problématiques de la
ville et je crois qu'on peut les
attribuer peut-être à des problématiques
de de logistique pour rebondir sur ce
que disait madame la présidente c'est
vrai qu'on a quand même assisté a
parfois des
des problématiques d'arrivée de
commandes de masques par des dus à des
commandes locales avec des
problématiques aux douanes en
particulier ce que les douanes ont été
beaucoup sollicités pour des
problématiques de normes de masques
commandés en marge du circuit étatiques
et on parlait à l'instant des des
conseils d'administration des ars mes
conseils d'administration ou de
surveillance dans l'est dans les
hôpitaux dans les ehpad qui sont qui
sont dans lesquels siègent des élus
locaux est effectivement la question
c'est est-ce que ces élus locaux n'ont
ils pas eu assez de de pouvoir puisque
on a eu une course un petit peu à la
demande de masques à un moment donné où
certains élus locaux se sont émus du
fait que l'état n'avait pas apporté à
ces masques au bon moment alors même
qu'ils avaient donc des responsabilités
dans ces conseils d'administration et de
surveillance sur lesquels ils pouvaient
donc entraîner une une commande de
masques dans les hôpitaux dont les ehpad
donc peut-être n'ont-ils pas assez
pouvoir foot ils ont encore augmenté le
pouvoir de ces élus qui étaient
préoccupés à l'avance par le manque de
masques manifestement oui c'est enfin il
ya deux points il ya d'abord ces les
établissements qui sont qui gère pour
leur propre compte
ceci étant se pose la question
effectivement de comme ce que la
proposition que nous avons fait de
passer d'un conseil de surveillance de
la rsa un conseil d'administration
peut-être faut-il se reposer la question
dans les établissements de santé
effectivement du conseil de surveillance
et conseils nutrition qui était un vieux
débat qui a été tranché à quelques
années / / / / / / le les les
initiatives des différents
des différentes collectivités parce que
tout le monde a essayé de 2 commandés
par ces circuits pour avoir il ya eu là
aussi je peux en témoigner avec le
préfet de région et des préfets en
général et leur service une bonne
coordination pour justement faire en
sorte que dans les douanes il ya un
travail de façon à ce que les masques
finissent par arriver dans le cadre de
la réquisition il y avait un sujet un
moment donné qu'on a réussi à rebondir à
transformer de façon à ce que les
masques de la ville de canton puisse
venir à la ville de lyon parce que
s'était adressé à la ville de lyon dans
le cadre du partenariat du jumelage dont
il ya eu un travail assez assez étroit
avec les services de la préfecture du
préfet de région du même et je le redis
encore combien cette ce travail en
commun a été vraiment formidable dans un
contexte qui était ou qui est toujours
mais beaucoup moins mais qui était très
très très tendue à l'époque oui quelques
quelques questions complémentaires en
vous remerciant en terme de cette
audition d'abord vous avez travaillé
avec avec l'eprus l'eprus a été englobé
dernièrement dans santé public français
ce que ça vous paraît une réforme qui a
été préjudiciable à la capacité de cet
établissement public était une
administration resserré de mission et
qui a vu ses missions un peu augmenté
fortement et donc peut être un peu
diluée est ce que justement sur cette
cette réactivité nécessaire sur cette
capacité à aller chercher les koval lme
les commandes les masques en période de
crise d'anticiper est ce que la
structure plus grande a été
a été un avantage ou un inconvénient
ensuite je voudrais je reviendrai sur
cette question parce que je crois
qu'elle est comme vous nous avez bien
éclairé sur les stocks stratégiques et
on peut relever que lorsque vous étiez
en responsabilité ces stocks étaient
bien tenus
la maison était bien tenu et que vous
avez vous avait anticipé les choses et
on était à ce niveau qui était
recommandé par le haut conseil de santé
publique et c'est finalement la dernière
période où ce stock de milliards même
beaucoup plus été et est garanti mais
j'ai voyagé j'ai aujourd'hui 7
ce sentiment d'un préparation et ça plus
en tant qu'acteur de terrain par rapport
à ce qui s'est passé dans les
établissements médico-sociaux et dans
les établissements hospitaliers alors tu
réellement vous avez très longuement et
sont très claires expliqué que cela
relevait de la responsabilité de ces
établissements on a vu que ça n'a pas
marché
que ce soit dans les établissements pu
les ehpad qu'ils soient publics ou
privés ce qui est encore peut-être plus
étonnant parce que des grands groupes
qui auraient dû être particulièrement
réactif à disposer de ces stocks de
d'équipements de protection et au delà
des masques de divers équipements le gel
hydroalcoolique les surblouse bon on a
vu des conséquences très graves danser
dans ces établissements on l'a vu aussi
pour les établissements hospitaliers
donc comment quelles réformes de même
parce que là c'est manifestement le
débat y pas de savoir ça va marcher on
verra peut-être la faute à qui mais
c'est un échec collectif
ça n'a pas marché ces établissements
n'avaient pas les équipements s du
chèque
ils ont pas pu bénéficier un stock plus
global d'une centralisation plus
efficace d'une répartition plus efficace
qu quelles propositions en tant qu
expert reconnu que vous êtes
on pourrait dégager pour dire demain si
la deuxième vague que ce matin le
professeur delfraissy semblait redouter
avec des mots assez clair intervient au
mois d'octobre
qu'est ce que c'est établi comment ces
établissements se dote est-ce qu'ils ont
la capacité chacun à faire des commandes
est-ce qu'on recentralise au moins au
niveau public ses commandes et on l'est
quelle quelle est la stratégie pour
qu'on se retrouve pas un jour à nouveau
autant dépourvu ou moi je l' ai vécu en
tant que c'est un président du
département toujours conseiller
départemental où le département des
alpes-maritimes disposer de huit cent
mille masques qui datait de d'avant 2009
et qui pour la plupart dans un premier
temps avait été jugé inutilisable puis
dans un second temps a été jugé par
votre délégué territorial valides qui
ont été distribués aux ehpad et qui ont
été données pour une partie au chu de
nice bon comment on demain on est plus
en plus efficaces
merci monsieur le rapporteur juste sur
le plan je n'ai pas de je peux pas vous
dire je n'ai pas d'avis sur le fait que
l'eprus soient entrés dans l'année spe
par rapport à manger pas suffisamment
vécu de situations délicates pour
pouvoir le constater je pense que ce
qu'il faut par contre c'est que et je
crois que c'est le cas c'est que
l'émission initialement de l'eprus soit
retrouvée intégralement est faite de la
même façon au sein d'un effet quelle que
soit l'enveloppent il ya entoure ces
missions je pense que c'est le sujet je
n'ai pas d'avis ou de d'éléments pour
pour vous pour vous dire quoi que ce
soit sur ce sur ce changement de deux
cadres qui est survenu trois en 2016 je
n'étais j'étais en région j'ai pas j'ai
pas j'ai pas je peux pas vous donner
d'avis vraiment là-dessus par contre sur
les éléments dans le cadre de votre
intervention qu'il y aurait à réfléchir
je pense que qualitativement et
quantitativement et qualitativement est
structurellement je pense qu'il ya
quelque chose que nous avons tous
collectivement découvert en focalisant
sur les masses que c'est que c'est
finalement les masques c'était une chose
mais les équipements de protection
les blues les sur blues et charlotte
certain nombre de choses et on était un
des sujets
pour les personnels dans les ehpad en
particulier mais pas seulement et où on
est revenu dans certains hôpitaux
vous savez au aux tissus à l'époque qui
ont été voilà oui ou bien ou bien des
sacs poubelle comme vous dites ou des
organisations et ses stocks
enfin c'est ces dispositifs ne n'était
pas quoi qu'il arrive dans les stocks
nationaux dans les stocks stratégiques
absolument pas des masques oui mais les
stocks les opinons je pense que là il ya
une réflexion à voir travers ce qu'on a
vécu sur après la manière mais en tout
cas à faire un sort particulier ses
équipements dont on parle jamais mais
quand on s'est aperçu que c'était
fondamental plus structurellement jeu je
me permets mais mon grand âge me permet
depuis sous serment mais je pense qu'il
faudra pas attendre trop longtemps
au delà d'une deuxième vague pour
prendre pour revoir le circuit de
distribution voir le les stocks la
nature des stocks de reversât je ne
pense pas que ce soit un travail
considérable pas travail considérable
c'est un travail à mon avis danse
d'assemblée liés et de de régénérer
cette doctrine sur un mode
plus plus plus modernes j'allais dire ou
plus adapté parce que tous aient tous
ces dispositifs je me permets de le dire
quand même une crise de cette envergure
là heureusement on la voit très rarement
mais c'est qu'entre les crises tant
qu'il n'ya pas de crise c'est vrai aussi
pour le dispositif
je reviens à mon propos introductif
c'est que souvenons nous de 2000
2011 fin 2010 ou à la suite de l'achat
et n'a quand même le pays par ses
représentants où je trouvais qu'on avait
fait beaucoup et que tout ceci mérite et
peut-être réflexion de nous continuons à
entasser et il ya quand même je pense
qu'il faut qu'on fasse à 2 de contourner
cette réflexion de ce combien de vies
mais de façon moderne adapté structuré
et puis qu'on qu'on sache qu'on sache
revoir nos procédures de façon plus plus
clair et plus plus simple jeu je vois
les choses que j'aurais à dire tout de
suite je pense qu'il y aura d'autres
réflexions qui viendront mais je pense
qu'il faut pas qu'on attende je pense
qu'à la rentrée fin il faut qu'on se
plonge sur ça et ne pas laisser quelque
chose
retourner et puis revoir nos précieux
parce que ce qui était bon à une époque
maintenant qu'on n'utilise pas après ça
va et puis c'est un lot de
malheureusement de c'est donc il faut
rester vigilant et dernier point
peut-être si je peux me permettre c'est
il faut sûrement que tous les ans lors
d'une discussion du plfss l'état des
stocks soient affichés vous venez
d'entendre jean yves grall ancien
directeur général de la santé il est
revenu sur les difficultés à évaluer les
besoins en masques notamment cette
audition ainsi que toutes celles de la
commission denquête sont à retrouver
tout l'été sur lcp et sur notre site
internet lcp point fr